hi this is Dan Adelman the half of
Thomas have games that isn't actually
Thomas hat I'll be sharing some tips and
tricks for new players of axiom verge to
do that I'm actually going to go into
speed run mode the benefit of speed run
mode is that it removes all of the
cutscenes and story based elements and
lets us jump right into the gameplay but
when you play the game for the first
time you should definitely just start up
a new game in regular mode to get the
full experience if you're new to the
genre you'll notice that the environment
will actually teach you how to play
without bogging you down with tutorials
for example you'll notice that the path
to the right is blocked which lets you
know you sometimes need to go left this
by the way is no Majda metroid which
starts off the same way definitely keep
an eye out for these environmental cues
here you'll notice that there's no way
out unless you shoot through these red
blobs which teaches you how to shoot and
navigate your way through the
environment
one thing I noticed when watching new
players is that they die quickly when
they just try to run through the
environment almost every enemy you
encounter can actually either be avoided
completely or destroyed from a position
where you can hit them but they can't
hit you I recommend taking your time as
you go through the different rooms and
see if you can find a plan of attack
that will keep you safe for example
there's no way for me to avoid this
enemy completely if I just run up to it
the bugs that keep spawning from it will
damage me but if I jump up onto this
platform I can attack it safely
sometimes the best spot to attack from
will require you to shoot at an angle to
do that hold down the L button to lock
your position and keep yourself from
moving around while you shoot we're
about to meet the first boss I won't
show you the entire fight but i'll show
you how to approach it you'll notice
that this boss has two different attacks
first are these projectiles that do
damage on impact you'll need to keep
shooting while avoiding these I like
standing on these blocks locking my
position and just shooting it the boss
until I need to move out of the way the
second attack is similar to the first
but it only does damage after it
explodes which is a second or two after
it hits the ground just make sure where
you're stepping so you're not in the
blast radius when it goes off
exploration is a big theme in axiom
verge if you ever find that you're not
sure where to go next be sure to check
your map on the gamepad there's probably
some door you haven't gone through yet
or room that you haven't finished
exploring here we find probably the most
distinctive upgrading the game the
address disruptor the address disruptor
lets you glitch the environment and
enemies to uncover hidden secrets
throughout the world as in the beginning
of the game there's no way to progress
here until you demonstrate your ability
to use the address disruptor by
glitching these platforms into existence
every creature an axiom verge can be
glitched some enemies in there glitched
form become helpful in some way some
become more aggressive and some just do
bizarre things as i mentioned
exploration is a primary theme of the
game so i definitely encourage you to
try glitching every enemy type at least
once for example you may remember this
enemy type from the beginning of the
game if I glitch it instead of spawning
bugs to attack me it now spawns health
glitching these round pink guys makes
them able to break through walls which
will allow you to get access to a hidden
powerup
and notice how if I glitch this guy all
of the enemies of the same type also get
glitched and if I destroy one I destroy
them all these are just some of the ways
that exploration and experimentation
will aid you on your mission this has
been Dan Adelman from Thomas app games
and I hope you enjoyed these tips and
tricks for axiom verge